[Music]
uh the milwaukee district attorney john
chris uh chis uh chisholm chisholm uh
chisholm now blaming an inexperienced
prosecutor for freeing the wakasha
waukesha waukesha parade attack suspect
on low bail before the attack
i'm not here to make excuses um i i own
every decision that's made by any member
of my office we had a young ada trying
to do the very best she could under
really difficult circumstances and she
made a mistake
so why aren't they considering bail
reform policies the root of the problem
many people do joining us now to react
is our fox and friends weekend crew we
have pete hegseth rachel compost duffy
and will kane today i will start with
you pete at the bottom what's your
reaction
well good morning my reaction is what
fantastic leadership that's what i was
taught in the military every time you
make a mistake
point downhill and blame somebody else
and only thing he has to blame is that
he's raised very faithful good wolkster
junior da's who are more than happy to
follow his policy of set minimum bail
possible and let criminals free i guess
i'm going to start i mean i want to make
light of it but it's such a serious
topic how do you say that looking the
families in the eye right those elderly
and that young kid jackson sparks by
saying sorry it's just a mistake
i don't really take any responsibility
for it
yeah will
yeah a mistake was made that just so
happens to support the policy proposal
i've been pushing for quite some time
right chisholm has been pushing bail
reform for quite some time now all of a
sudden a mistake seems to fall in line
with the policy he pursues you know
steve what's fascinating is let's say
that what he's saying is true the ada
didn't have a pre-trial risk assessment
she didn't get it uploaded she didn't
see how dangerous daryl brooks was let's
say a mistake truly did happen
what would she fall back on she would
fall back on culture and instinct and
pleasing the boss we would all have a
baseline from which we would perform and
she would perform like well this is what
my boss likes this is what i want let's
go with a low bail that's what's most
just this ultimately mistake or not
comes back to chisholm comes back to the
d.a rachel what i find amazing is i've
watched the coverage on other channels
they never bring up when it comes to
looting uh proposition 47 and they never
bring up when they cover the story and
they don't cover it much they never
bring up bail reform they know it's bad
they don't want to bring it up it's
almost as if the democrats are colluding
with the media on everything
you're absolutely right the stories that
you get just did earlier about all the
looting
are absolutely related to this story
pete and will are right this was office
policy this was not a mistake and this
ta is well known in wisconsin by the way
he was the one who went after his
political enemies he went after walker's
team he did knock raids early morning
knock raids scaring the heck out of his
political enemies treating them like
hardened criminals and then letting
letting these guys go this is a leftist
policy it's being pushed by george soros
by eric holder who have been putting in
da's just like chisholm who has been
there for a long time by the way um and
and they this is part of their whole
policy this is their whole world view
and now people died because of it and he
is such a loser and a liar this is his
policy for him to blame that young d.a
is wrong she was doing exactly what he
wanted her to do rachel how do how do
leaders like like chisholm get positions
like that i mean you're from this area
wisconsin from what we've heard that
area is very republican and conservative
and everyone goes to church on sundays
are they all up in arms or people what
are people saying yes
this guy's done this guy is done because
this has now he's been exposed i think
people thought oh these are nice
policies and you know i think people
were trying to give the benefit of the
doubt
now they're seeing um in in plain view
what happens when you put weak da's in
with these kinds of policies you get
crime you get you get death
will this weekend on fox and friends
weekend you've got the two singers
songwriters who have the number one song
in america
we do we also have another
singer-songwriter in john rich we have
mike rowe we have lara trump we have dan
bongino i've got it written down
uh lieutenant colonel allen west hello
steve lieutenant west is running for
governor of texas uh he's going to be
joining us i always appreciate you brian
really good because i'm rick you rarely
do have said you appreciate me so this
is kind of enjoying breaking news john
rich and mike rowe have the number one
song in america with sam has got a dirty
job which is a fundraiser for folds of
honor and mike rowe works rachel how's
the book coming along great
rachel can you hear me how's the book
coming along yeah
great so they have the number one song
we have the number one christmas book in
america that's the book right there
we're excited we're so excited that all
three of you were able to participate in
the book um i think it's bringing people
a lot of cheer a lot of joy
people want to hold on to their
traditions they've been disrupted over
the last two years and this book is a
reminder of american christmas
traditions through the eyes of so many
of our fox news friends so
it's the perfect gift order it now
you'll get it in time for christmas for
all of the people who love fox news on
your christmas list
and speaking of great gifts this holiday
season sign up for fox nation to use
promo code celebrate to get 35 percent
off any yearly subscription along with
rachel and sean's all-american christmas
book for a limited time only at
foxnation.com pete uh do you have
anything you would like to say for 15
seconds
oh man
i guess in spirit of the well in spirit
of the topic uh when i make a mistake on
the weekend brian because i sit where
you sit i'm going to blame you if you
don't mind from now yeah
i totally accept it it'll be fantastic
and then the culture it's a culture
we blame him for everything the culture
you create on the couch from monday
through friday causes me to make
mistakes on saturday and sunday all
right rachel will pete thank you very
much